okay so without further ado Nevada mr.
Vina from University of Utah talk about
Titan under theory in outer space
thank you okay so I'd like to thank the
organizers this is my very first
all-fours bears and I'm really honored
to be here so my plan is to to talk
about outer space so I think many of you
know that I've been thinking about this
for a few years now and I should say
that the theory is largely motivated by
thank you another theory this that's
what you know that we we know what we're
supposed to be proving but looking at
tightener theory and particularly in
particular works of say bears and and
Thurston in the old days and then more
recently mainstream Minsky and then even
more recently Rafi however this being in
the Halloween season you should you
should expect to to see a dark and
shadowy world with monsters lurking in
the background so in many ways you know
the out offend world is is you know one
way to put it is to say less nice more
challenging but it's also I think more
interesting I think from from a point of
view of somebody working in out of there
fin you know mapping class groups and
taking another space look fairly tame
somehow basically everything that that
can go wrong probably does in the outer
fend world okay so so so I'm going to
try to explain part of this world to
someone who is maybe familiar or
somewhat familiar with tackle military
okay so that's the plane okay so the I
will start by defining what outer space
is so the first section is and I'm going
to be developing kind of a dictionary as
I go along and the dictionary says this
is this is time
this was defined in the eighties by
color and both men you mean closer to my
mouth I guess okay
how's that better let's see I guess if I
talk like this this isn't out there felt
phenomenon here yeah how about now okay
alright I can also just try to yell
forget the record okay okay so so this
was defined at color and Altman in the
eighties and it goes like this it's so
CBN this is going to be the space of
pairs if you want consisting of a metric
graph so gamma is a metric graph and by
graph I always been finite
nobody wants one volume one okay so the
sum of the lengths of the assigning a
number a length to every edge and the
sum is supposed to be one and ng here is
so-called marking it's a home of the
equivalents from some fixed graph like
the rows of rank n so our n is the just
a legend in circles like this to gamma
so this is just supposed to tell you how
to identify the fundamental group of
gamma with the free group this RN is
just once and for all to fixed graph so
you can see the resemblance between this
definition
consider surface a hyperbolic structures
or surfaces instead of instead of metric
structures and graphs and there's an
equivalence here if if if you have two
of these so here's here's GE and here's
G Prime going to gamma and gamma prime
so these two things will define the same
point in in outer space
if there is an isometry in other words a
homeomorphism which preserves the length
of edges so that this diagram communites
up to homotopy okay so that's the
equivalence there is a picture that one
can draw in in rank two and that's as
far as we can go this thing has
dimension 3n minus four is that right
six yeah okay so in ring tool you start
to draw the picture by but you know you
give yourself a little circle just to
guide your picture but the circle is not
part of the of the space and then your
tessellated by my ideal triangles just
like just like the modular group
tessellation of the plane and these
triangles represent families of graphs
that have the same underlying underlying
graph but the metric varies so for
example this big triangle over here will
correspond to some fixed graph like this
where you have lengths of edges a B and
C and they have to add up to one so that
describes two simplex but notice that
the vertices of the simplex are not in
this place because it will correspond to
to the situation where two of these
numbers are zero and it's not allowed
because you're then getting a graph
that's not it's not normal to pick more
than two to the rows anymore
now when you when you approach the face
of one of these triangles then one of
these edges will shrink and you'll just
end up with the edges collapsed then we
can proceed
to the next triangle and you'll get the
same looking graph as before but it will
have a different market you should think
of of you know taking one of these
circles and flipping it over and then
and then I'm collapsing the middle edge
for example okay so that that in the
first approximation this is outer space
in in rank two there there is certain
annoying addition to this because there
also there's one more shape of graphs
that you have to worry about namely this
sort of thing and so it turns out that
that you have to add triangles like this
on top of this picture you have to
attach along the base of the triangle
to agree to every edge in this picture
and and these sides are not in the not
in the picture because they correspond
to collapse in one of the circles okay
so in general CBN is the outer space
here is a complex it's not a simple
complex it's a complex of simplices with
missing faces so simplices the missing
face
okay so here the zero dimensional faces
are missing and then in this picture
even one dimensional it is contractible
that somehow the main topological fact
about in general it is not it is not a
manifold I mean here you can kind of
cheat and say well let's not attach
these and just keep the just ignore
graphs with separating edges and that's
that's a legitimate thing to do and it
helps you in rank two but in hiring
it doesn't it doesn't help you even if
you delete those simplices the space
will still not be a meaningful it's not
a manifold okay so this is one of the
one of the monsters but on the other
hand all their fan which the dictionary
says is is the it acts it acts by by
change of a change of marking just like
in the case of a massive cluster if I if
I have an autumn or visible free group I
can view it as a as a homo type
equivalence of the rows then I can just
compose okay you can also you can talk
about the thick part just like in tech
another space so this just means that
it's it's the subset where where there
are no loops shorter than some fixed
number epsilon all right so all loops
loops length so the length of a loop is
you just add up the lengths of edges
that it crosses and the action of our
defend is proper on outer space and it's
compact on the thick part so this is
you can in fact even even go all the way
down to the spine there's an actual
spine which is somehow dual to to the to
the missing faces so for example for the
for the triangle with missing vertices
the dual spine would look like this you
take the barycentric subdivision and you
only keep the simplest sister this joint
throwing the missing phases and you do
this for every simplex in your in outer
space and that's going to give you a
deformation which actually has the right
dimension it has the the dimension of
the spine is a virtual coma logical
dimension of okay now let's talk about
the boundary so this was also introduced
in the 80s by Connor and shaylen where
colors are colored Morgan and the way
the way this works so this is the
dictionary says this is this is PML so
this is supposed to be analogous to the
Thurston boundary of tacular space so
you think of you can think of
alternatively you can think of cvn the
outer space by taking universal coverage
you can think of a point as being an
action of the pretty group on the tree
so this is really the same as free
simplicial F entries and then instead of
normalizing but by volume you can just
say mother by homothetic
for example okay and then this sits
inside a larger space where you don't
insist on the trees being free and
solutions you just omit though you allow
non free and you are non simplicial
trees as well so this this is inside the
space of
just please was that a three with an F
in action FN is acting isometrically on
the simple to just take universal cover
of of one of these objects like for
example the Rose taking a missile cover
that gives just three okay so FN threes
/ and you can take you can take the
closure of this object of CBN inside
here and that's that's the that's the
compactification coloring and morgan
prove that that this is in fact compact
this is sorry this is not equal in fact
yeah so so what's an example of
something of something that that shows
up here but not here
well so for example I can take well just
to start if you take a surface and you
take if you take one of these
laminations let's say complementary
components are ideal polygons so in
universal cover Universal cover you see
you see a picture like this one and so
now you can you can form a dual object
to do all object to this picture
upstairs
is is a three where I have a branch
point vertices or bench points are going
to be dense typically in in a tree
that's in the closure here so I would
take a point there would be a point in
the dual object for each one of these
complementary regions and I can measure
the distance between two such points by
using the transfers measure I can
measure gives me a 3 which is called an
artery so there is a dual artery so so
an example is so T could be 3
dual to a measured elimination on a on a
surface now if the surface is closed it
has the wrong fundamental group so I
really want the surface is boundary or
surfaces punctures and that's going to
give me an F entry okay no more
generally there are so now we are
getting into the monster part of this
section you know so if all three is in
here look like that then life would be
good but they don't so more generally
there are three there are three T in the
boundary of cvn they're not dual to
elimination of the surface they're dual
to two measured lamination they say to
complex which is not a surface and just
to give you a little picture to think
about one way to construct lamination so
surfaces is to take an interval exchange
map so you take take some interval and
you cover it by your partition it into
sub intervals and you then you rearrange
the other way and and then let's say
this is ABC and then and then you can
glue bands to this so you take a you
take a band that goes off this way and
then it's glued here and you do it all
all pairs B to B C to C that's going to
give you a surface with a well here in
this case it's a foliation but you can
also think about this lamination
now this more general object with when
you have a too complex you can you can
you can think of that as having these
collections of intervals
bears of intervals that don't form
partitions of the interval they they
look like something like this
here's your interval and and then there
is maybe a like this see so they don't
form a partition in some places they
overlap in some places they don't cover
on average they cover and then and then
they're also these so maybe there's a B
and but it's something like that so you
have places that are covered only once
and then you have places they're covered
more than twice but on average things
are covered twice and then you do the
same thing you glue these your glue use
bands and you get a some kind of a
complex to the foliation on it measured
foliation and the dual object is you
know depending on how you choose these
lengths and so on but there are a lot of
points on the boundary of outer space
that are dual tool I mean to a foliation
like that now even more generally this
so this is all stuff in the eighties the
trees like this can be understood using
something called the ribs machine and
this thing is the dictionary says this
is this is like the beach but it's it's
a little bit more general because
because you have to handle these more
general patterns of pairs of intervals
but but even even that doesn't describe
all threes in the boundary so this was
this was all understood in maybe early
90s but much more recently by the work
of Goldberg Hylian glue stick and
Reynolds so even more generally so
tea in the boundary of CBN is typically
a dual to a measured so this this will
have to be put in quotes lamination on
on the face which is not even the too
complex it's a space built of
it's sort of a complex it's a complex
built built out of compact trees so a
dendrite to take a dendrite may be
infinitely many branch points a compact
metric tree out of dendrite dendrites so
you see one of these old-fashioned
complexes was built out of but nobody
place intervals here by by compact trees
and then you build you build a space out
of those things cross I build looks of a
bit complex out of that and then the
claim is that the typical between the
boundary is described but object like
that and there's a there is a
generalized art machine that that
handles things like this
okay
I'm stopping with this section this is
this really is typical in the sense of G
Delta dance you know I mean principal in
principal we now understand every single
point before in the old days we had to
approximate so these are called
geometric threes and then and then these
guys are non geometric and they could
geometric but now we we understand what
they look like okay number three yes
correct okay so this is another another
sort of monster so you want to have
intersection number like if you have to
measure laminations on the surface then
there is a well-defined intersection
number well if you have two trees well
there is a there is a notion of
intersection over but it doesn't behave
well it turns out that the the dual
space in other words instead of just
having one space PML would well define
intersection number we actually have two
spaces and the pairing is defined
between them okay so it's not a
self-dual object if you want two spaces
okay so this is in the dictionary this
is also PML but the other eight PML in
the first approximation this is the
completion completion of the space of
conjugacy class
see if you have a simple course curb on
the surface then you can either view it
as such you can just think of it as a
simple cost curve on the surface or you
can take the universal cover and take
the dual of object and think of it as as
an action of the surface group on the
tree and in in the PML world both of
these points of view lead to pretty much
the same space but in in in out event
they don't they give you two different
spaces okay so more precisely a current
so a current is you take the boundary of
the free group which is can twist it and
take pairs of points and you delete it
they're gonna so you think of a point in
here as being aligned all right with
endpoints and infinity and you divide by
by the flipped z2 oriented lines don't
measure you should just think of that as
being as meaning that compact sets have
finite measure and they measure on the
compact says determines so you should
just think of this is being really
defined on compact set and to make it
more concrete how do you so say if G is
a conjugacy class how do you assign to
it a measure like this and then so so
here I'm going to draw the free group is
a circle it's easier to draw a circle
than to draw a counter set but it's
supposed to be and now if I have a
compact suppose I have a compact setting
in this space so that really means I
have maybe to compact to this joint
compact sets there's two disjoint
compact sets in the boundary and they
determine a single compact set in here
and I look at I look at the lifts of G
so the lift of G there will be
infinitely many lifts a G some of them
will
go from A to B so I count how many and
that's the measure so that's the
counting measure the number of lifts
okay let's go from A to B and then take
the closure in the space of measures and
that and there is a disappearing so so
first of all this space the space of
space of all current current this is
this is a it's a convex cone
infinite-dimensional except in dimension
2 but I mean in rank to rank two it's
not in for the measure
well now the way I actually the way I
defined it it is in reality there is a
slightly smaller space that people work
with and that one is finally dimensional
in rank - but in high rank is also
infinity okay so convex infinite
dimensional cone like this you can you
can scale measures you can you can take
positive linear combinations and the
projective ization is compact
yes so it's it very much looks like PML
except that it's infinite dimensional
but the good the good news is that there
is a pairing so you can so there is a
pairing between currents and and I
didn't use this word before but very
small trees so the trees in here are
called very small the ones that are the
ones that are in CB n bar these are
called very small trees and there is a
there is a characterization genes which
I won't get into but anyway so very
small trees so here I'm not projective
izing I'm taking taking and there is a
map into infinity which is continuous
and it extends so this is a and it
extends the the the obvious pairing on
so if I take if I take Mooji here they
take one of these currents that I
constructed over there and I take some
tea in it CBN then there's kind of only
one thing this can be this is the
translation length of G and T or if you
want you realize G is a loop in the
quotient in this graph and you look at
the length
of GMT and these things are dense in
these faces so this this rule uniquely
determine is disappearing yes
oh yes yes I do I forgot that thank you
F an invariant F in the variant thank
you
well that's you know the space of
measures space of probability measures
in a compact space week star topology
okay no now we get to the exciting part
metric I have eight bits here okay
number four is the Lipschitz metric and
the dictionary says that this is you
know this could be Thank You Mueller
metric it sort of has features of all
three of these Pearson we only have one
there's only one so for useful metric
well there's there's also you can also
symmetrize as you'll see we don't have
okay so so let's say I have two points
and so here's my CBN and they take two
points that so there's G gamma and this
D prime gamma Prime and I want to
determine the distance between them so I
look at my diagram so first there's a
homotopy class of maps as determined by
this picture then we you put you put the
map here say F so that it's diagram
community if you can if you can put an
isometry then then the two points are
the same but you can always put a map
okay and this map is called the
difference of markings
and you try to minimize the the Lipchitz
constant which you can do
where's Ellis Cooley so you take the
minimal possible Lipschitz constant and
you call that number say Sigma ok so and
then I will drop G&G prime from the
patient so I'll just have Sigma of gamma
gamma prime is constant okay and the
distance is declared to be the log of
this number by definition is log of
Sigma so for example the distance from
gamma 2 gamma is 0 because it's log of 1
right the minimum Lipschitz constant is
going to be 1/4 and maybe it's slightly
trickier to prove that if the distance
is 0 then then ok so let's work out an
example so I say let's say I look at the
following picture I have I have here's a
graph I want the length of this loop to
be 1/4 1/4 1/2 and then over here I'll
have maybe a different looking graph
like this where all I just have going on
quarter okay and I want the difference
of markings F to send this vertex to
let's say a point in the middle here so
I'm just giving you a map and then and
then these it's supposed to be obvious
what to do with the rest so if I take if
I take a loop like this here's the left
loop well let you go to the left loop so
I'm just going like this this way and
then go around here and then come back
and likewise the right loop will go over
here and then this top loop will will go
to sort of an obvious map
now if you think about what the slopes
are you will see that the slope is the
slope on each edge if you imagine that
the map is linear constant slope on
every edge then then the slope is equal
to two on on these two and it's equal to
one okay so what
so certainly Sigma is less than or equal
to two
but I want to convince you that you
cannot do better that the two is really
the best you can do here and the reason
for this is that we so we look at this
graph where the slope is maximum which
is this graph here and traditionally
this is called the green graph the
organizer didn't supply green chalk but
it's okay that's white it's okay it's
okay we can we can call it a white graph
just today okay now in addition the
there is an extra structure that this
graph comes with just by looking at this
picture so this is called a train track
structure so what is the frame track
structure it is it is just an
equivalence relation on the set of
directions out of Fe
is an equivalence relation on the set of
directions and there is going to be a
train track structure on this sub graph
so I'm going to call so Delta of F this
is the tension graph okay so this is
where the through maximal stretch
happens we call the tension graph and
this graph comes with the track
structure what is the train track
structure I take - I need an equivalence
relation on these four directions out of
this vertex well declare the two of them
are equivalent if F or more precisely
the derivative of that I think of these
as kind of tangent vectors are mapped to
the same direction in the target okay so
so two directions D 1 is equivalent to D
2 if and only if the F star is equal to
2 so here in this picture these two
directions on the left are equivalent
because they both go to the direction
here and the other two are also close to
each other so traditionally you're
supposed to draw this picture like so
you threw out a tension graph like that
you throw a global injections into the
tangent way and there's there's a notion
of a legal loop a loop is legal or a
path a path in Delta of F is legal if if
at every vertex I didn't so an
equivalence class is called the gate
okay so if at every vertex the enter
gate is different from the exit all
right so any any kind of a smooth path
here yes you're allowed to come in and
then turn around make a sharp turn and
go back illegal and notice that if you
take any illegal loop its length in the
target is exactly two times the length
in the source all these edges get
stretched by a factor of two and and the
loop remains immersed by the legality
condition and that means that you cannot
do better if there is a loop that
stretches by a factor of two then
there's no way you're going to have a
Lipschitz map with Lipschitz constant
less than two so this this train track
structure on this sub graph it's kind of
a witness to the fact that you cannot do
better so this is kind of like the
quadratic differential in Integris
theorem and in fact that's the let me
state the theorem which is really
analogous
okay so for every gamma gamma Prime
there is a difference of markings map
called an optimal map and dictionary is
that this is the thank you map
unfortunately it's not unique its
floppiness here but the properties are
so one is that it minimizes which is
Sigma of Sigma of gamma gamma prime F
has slope gap lambda lambda on a
subgraph well the subgraph Delta F is a
potential graph if you if you're
thinking analogy with with the Thurston
metric then this would be the you know
there is a measured lamination that that
is morally equivalent to this sort of
testifies that you cannot do better in
the Thurston metric and and F induces
the train tracks dr.
a train track structure on Delaware with
at least two gates at every vertex it
would not be very interesting to have a
train track structure with only one gate
because then you would use the you would
enter that vertex and you will stop you
would not be able to exit okay so that's
okay now the the metric is is not
symmetric and there are easy examples
just about I mean just pick any two
random points it's probably then going
from here to here and and the map is
just there homeomorphism if you want one
so here the stretch is 1 minus epsilon
over 1/2 so it's 2 times 1 minus epsilon
then you have to take the log of that
right that's the going from here to here
if you go the other way then this
epsilon loop has to stretch all the way
to 1/2 this distance is bounded by log 2
no matter how small we make the epsilon
so so it's cheap to go to infinity in
outer space converges to 0 you're
converging to one of the missing
vertices so we're going to infinity in
outer space but it's expensive to come
back so you should you should be careful
when somebody offers you cheap ride into
outer space you always always ask let's
ask for the price of the return trip
and this is somehow a new phenomenon I
mean for these thematics this two of
these are symmetric and asymmetric is
not symmetric but it is still it's still
it's not finite distance to infinity in
fact when you have a metric space that
that's not where the metric is not
symmetric then there are two kinds of
Cauchy sequences you can consider if you
have a sequence of points you know in
the coachee condition you can always
measure the distance from a point to a
point in the you know future points in
the sequence or you can measure or
recognizer distances the other way
around from a more advanced point to a
less advanced point so there's kind of a
forward completion that this space is is
not forward complete well this this
example shows you that and the
completion was worked out by fear and
it's it's remarkably similar to to the
way Petersons completion and so forth
and but it is backwards it is backwards
complete
yes oh you can have it both ways here
whichever you like better complete or
not do this somehow you know in some
sense replaces the the you know the fact
that we don't have one but you can you
can think okay
folding pass so that the extra
dictionary is that these are these are
going to be geodesics in the in the in
delipcious metric but there are other
geodesics these are not the only
geodesics
there many geodesics but it somehow
preferred those behave pretty good
nicely so how they define well I will be
only lose here so if if you have an
optimal map like in the theorem optimal
and the tension graph is the whole thing
okay so that example is not good because
we don't know what to do with with edges
outside the tension graph the whole
thing and then we say well fold all
illegal turns at the same speed okay
then fold all illegal turns of this so
now we have a train track structure on
the whole gap for the whole graph gamma
fold all the legal turns with the same
speed
and this is going to produce a path say
gamma sappy let me just to give you a
local picture something like you know
maybe this is your your train track map
with three gates vertex these two edges
are in the same gate turn there so you
can just in this picture there's only
one in regal turn so the same speed
there's only one okay so you what you do
is you take a piece of this edge of
length T and a piece of this edge of
length T and you identify them so maybe
maybe the the optimal map anyway you
know just take a piece at time T you
take a piece of lengthy a piece of
lengthy and you identify so this is
going to factor through a graph like
that
yeah and that's like this if you do this
for all possible T's you'll get a path
this is of course more interesting when
when the map is complicated maybe you
have something like you know on Alta
morphism where a goes to a b b goes to b
a b and then it turns out that if you if
you take takes maybe take a high power
of this map with appropriate metrics and
then then this falling path will just
take you know take the bigger loop and
you'll fold it over the smaller loop and
and maybe as a result the bigger loop
will become smaller so it's kind of like
a continuous fraction expansion or
something you you're folding a bigger
loop over a smaller loop until it gets
smaller and then you do it the other way
around this on a typical folding path
looks like
alright okay so so number six this is
probably going to be the last one but
number six is so there's a
classification about the morphisms and
this is directly analogous to the work
of bears so the bears prove we proved
the Neilson there's some classification
about from the point of view ocular
theory and you can do exactly the same
thing in outer space using the ellipses
metric so the idea is that if you
suppose they give you an ultimatum well
this is going to act by minus on
and and and then you have the
displacement function visa fee and this
is just some function on defined in
since you can take a point in CBN which
is a graph and you look at its image
okay so that's any measure of the
distance between like to write the
action on the right you you still have
to be careful how you you know the order
is important here and then and then
there is a just a logical try colony
right you can say you can say the fee is
can be elliptic parabolic
okay so the elliptic means that the
infimum of the fee is zero and is
realized in other words there's a point
that's fixed by by this personage that's
the same thing as being olympic our
Volvic means that in this function is
positive and in parabolic just means
that the genome is not realized it could
be zero or positive but it's not really
okay
and in the surface situation elliptic
corresponds to finite order hyperbolic
corresponds to suit and also and
parabolic corresponds to reducible in in
outer space it's a little bit more
complicated namely the first part is
still okay so the the elliptic elliptic
still corresponds to find the order and
that's almost obvious I mean the the
elliptic means that there is a point
fixed by at the end if you examine
definitions that means that the autumn
orphism can be realize the symmetry of
the underlying graph
now the other two are not going to be if
and only if statements in fact it still
is still not completely understood which
which elements are hyperbolic but ok but
parabolic simile implies are reducible
but here's an example if I if I take say
a goes to a so here's another this one
is reducible because it has this
realized on a on the on the graph there
are big so the if you think about what
this map does here
it's Lipschitz constant is going to be
very close to one just slightly over one
so the so that means that the
displacement function on this graph is
very close to zero but it can never be
zero because this has so that shows that
this is parabolic same thing one is zero
but it's not realized reducible but
there are to do simple other morphisms
that are not they're not probable so
fully reducible fully reducible is is
what corresponds to being sued an
awesome this always implies hyperbolic
hyperbolic and and it translates and has
an invariant invariant folding path
along which it translates so that's kind
of like an axis and the translation
length is the translation like this log
of the dilatation just like
well it means that it does not preserve
the conjugacy class of any free factor
even after taking powers so there's no
periodic there's no free factor which
returns to itself may be conjugated
itself after taking powers this is so so
here a free factor is is analogous to
being a subsurface right so you can
define a suit and also they're saying
that it's something that where there is
no subsurface that returns to itself
after after taking powers but here
instead of saying some surface you say a
free factor and they get you get a
definition of a full irreducible and all
those guys are hyperbolic they translate
along some axis which is really a a
folding path which is like a geodesic
and it has the right information length
the translation like this log of the of
the location and this actually shows why
a metric like this has to be non
symmetric because it turns out that
there are autumn orifices in fact
typical automorphism is going to have
different growth rate then it's inverse
other person grows it one growth rate
the inverse grows at a different point
so if you want if you want the statement
about having translation like equal to
the log of the of the growth then you
you're forced
all right so so maybe I'll say a few
words about the more recent developments
this is complexes so these are complex
so here we we had only one metric while
the timer metrics with the complexes the
situation is reversed we have at least
three complexes that way there there are
three of them actually they're warmer
but there is a SN so this is the complex
so this is the free splitting and a
typical vertex in this complex is
represented by by a free product which
I'm so FN it's not a be like this and I
like to think of it as in terms of the
mass center correspondence this is a
free splitting of the typical vertex you
can imagine yeah so there are some
elementary moves that tell you how to
fill in the complex for example you can
split be as a free product to be one
star be two and then you can put be one
on the a side okay so that's a that's a
there's an edge in this complex let me
not talk about that too much time is
turning out okay and then there's the
free factor complex
see in the surface world if I give you a
subsurface then there is a there is a
unique complementary service in the free
in the free group setting if I give you
a there are many different beads you can
put here essentially different beads and
so in this complex we don't remember the
B we just remember the a ok so this is
the complex so this is kind of like the
profits building but instead of
subspaces of a vector space if you
consider three factors and simplices are
just going to be things you know black
and and then there's also a complex
which is ZN cyclic splitting complex and
their course maps so cv n coarsely maps
to this complex this course lives down
here it's course the maps down here for
example what is what is the map that
goes from well I just say let's forget
the cyclic splitting so just think about
going from here to here
well you just pick say a or you could
pick B but it turns out they're closed
in the in the free factor complex so
it's a well-defined course map these are
all likely variant course maps and
they're not quasi saw meters they're all
all these complexes are really different
and the theorem to do too
maybe too many people to list this way
our is that all all three are hyperbolic
and okay I mean this it'll go on and on
but there so I think you see that there
is kind of a reasonable theory that that
tries to mimic what's known for in a
technic Theory case but there there are
also many differences and there are so
many things we would like to know but we
don't
for example the the one that that's
bothering most of us is the lack of the
distance formula Mazur Minsky distance
formula where you can estimate the word
length in in our defend in terms of some
some data that come from these competent
I think